what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch Wednesday the
penultimate episode John how are you I am thrilled
and excited and Spooktacular sir how are you I'm
doing great doing great hoping this is a good one
with that in mind ladies and gentlemen you know
would help us out with this video if you leave
a like please go ahead and leave that like we'd
love it if you would leave that like secondly
subscribe and click the notification Bell get
notified when a reaction is over to the finale
that'd be very much appreciated as always foreign
exclusively over there several shows
reaction highlights and watch Longs
included I am done with this intro let's move on
foreign funerals I've been crashing them since
I was old enough to read the obituary section
what's your favorite obituary mayor Walker
was murdered and I know the Killer is here
and watching everything I do
started out of the soul I have all the pieces of
the jigsaw I just need to slap them into place
like the rainbow in between yeah yeah well
placed all the pieces are assembled [Music]
am I supposed to be mourning this mayor
because you seem like a pretty awful guy
don't worry I'm gonna start
crying any second now [Music]
oh this is definitely going to be the Killer
God that coat I want that coat [Music]
that's sweet still as sharp
as ever my pigtailed protege
oh a smile oh cool yes let's go I'm sorry you
said that he would be He Said Fred armisen's
playing him yeah I'm waiting for this just
blew into town this morning and was hit by a
wave of nostalgia I thought you didn't go
to Nevermore your dad got all the brains
he filled me in on what's been going on
Monsters murder Mayhem Mischief what fun
I'd be checking up on you what kind of job
the climate means I need someone to lay low
for a couple days spit off yeah I want to side
Series where Fester's going around whacking
people cooking fools this place belongs
to a friend you've actually made a friend
that poor kid will be going home in a body bag
oh spoke too soon I like a hideout that comes
with snacks or practically Eugene's
children that means do not eat them
what kind of a monster you're dealing
with haven't been able to identify it
it's called a hide a hide a hide in 83 during my
vacay at the Zurich Institute for the criminally
insane so I got my first lobotomy but you know
lobotomies they're kind of like tattoos you can't
just get one and even numbers are bad luck she
had it all beauty brains and a penchant for neck
nice let's go did you just change on her own no
idea I only saw her in group electroshock therapy
tried Nathaniel Faulkner's diary
okay where is it night shades Library
we'll sneak into the night trades library
tonight in the meantime lay low Fester
you're more perfect for this case if you
are discovered I will disown you and collect
other reward money tied to your capture and
expect nothing less and don't eat the bees
leave the bees alone
bees are endangered right now bees are friends
not food of course goody is nowhere to be found
when I need her that can be just as annoying
and unreliable as the living you're annoying
and unreliable unit speak of the devil how's
everything going Solitude suit suits me with
no annoying distractions I'm almost finished
with my novel was I an annoying distraction
you definitely had some annoying habits that
distracted me when you text which is a 24 7
addiction well Elise is not a migraine inducing
typewriter hammering into my head when you're not
grinding your canines you growl in your sleep as
opposed to late night cello solos complain about
them non-stop I dig that over your obsession
with all things creepy and dead you could gas
an entire small village with the amount of perfume
you spreads ouch Jesus fight fight hyoko and I are
so in sync that she's begging me to be her new
roomie permanently don't let me hold you back
you seem slightly affected I could see a romance
between them that would be interesting [Music]
did you know Jenna Ortega did not snap with her
left uh hand so she had to spend three months
learning does this really that's a very long
time I know people have trouble with it but God
you don't know who your real friends
are I've been on your side since day
one I literally saved your life it's true
you want honesty here it is every time the
monsters attacked you have been right there
starting with Rowan at the Harvest Festival
someone else has been right there the
whole time you arrived at the meeting
house just minutes after the monster had
disappeared yet you say you didn't see it
you're a mystery writer Wednesday
you know this is all too convenient
even Drew where it lived then
when Eugene went to investigate
you think I would hurt Eugene if I Am The Monster
why haven't I killed you poke the hole there
because for some reason I cannot fathom or
indulge you seem to like me what's the luck
a lot damn dude he's just making [__] up
yeah you know there's a lot to like just
trying to protect your prize desired girl
how long have you been lurking long
enough to feel the tension between you two
hello thing oh you can't still be mad about
the Kalamazoo job it wasn't my fault oh no
I'm finished enough
[Music] let him go show me the diary foreign
do I have time for a snooze or
can you crack this one quickly
thing doesn't need a
stethoscope or a Walkman [Music]
a cinch he's dormant to till Unleashed by a
traumatic event or unlock through chemical
inducement or hypnosis this act caused aside to
develop an immediate bond with its Liberator who
the creature now sees its Master becomes the
Willing instrument of whatever and Affairs
agenda this new master might propose interesting
so he's Tyler's being controlled that's right it's
none of it's his fault that means I'm not looking
for one killer but two exactly I said there were
toast dude I just thought there were two hides I'm
right there with you Wednesday we'll figure this
out together Homie we all finished the novel for
you Enid has requested a room with Yoko for the
rest of the school year you two seemed as thick as
thieves ultimately thieves turn on each other no
honor among Thieves part of the dorm experience
is making friends with people that you wouldn't
normally connect with and those friendships often
turn into lifelong bonds I would rather buy a rope
hahaha well if that's your decision I'll submit
the forms to principal Weems I wonder if they
give these seats to Christina Ritchie yeah
let's grab me some crazy like fan theory that
she's like she is still Wednesday from altering
yeah and sucked through a vortex Uncle Fester
Lobo has its perks you get to live by your
own rules do whatever you want just look at me
oh Fest how did he get in there so perfectly
I know how long did that take him yeah I know
where that is okay I can meet you there in like 20
minutes okay bye who are you talking to whoa how'd
you do that it's none of your goddamn business
I know what you are Xavier can you stay the hell
away from me nah come on Wednesday did you place
the tracker [Music] Uncle Fester's got you covered
it's so old school yes [Music] you
know me I like to travel incognito
it's the perfect color scheme this
episode feels very Adam's Family [Music]
that's Xavier all right [Music]
dang what God damn it Tyler you're confusing
the whole situation nah nah
don't lose don't lose weight
and she shall appear I've been reading about
hypnotherapy I think it might be a good technique
to unlock my inner Wednesday I applaud your new
willingness to delve deep into yourself yeah yeah
let's do some EMDR Wednesday canbot has
to be sages master the hide delays dormant
until Unleashed by a traumatic event or unlock
their chemical inducement or hypnosis [Music]
to figure out he was a hot and used
hypnotherapy to unlock him that would
explain their secret sessions I think the kid
behind the counter has clocked me foreign relax
[Laughter] need a refill on this puppy too
Tyler this is my Uncle Fester so Disturbed
Heights it's a better version of one of those
prank things from back in the 80s that's it
from that night your father gave you explicit
instructions not to be near me dad's not here
and I want to break and you came into the
shop apparently a high needs to be unlocked
get away from her
for the record Wednesday was trying to keep her
distance I was the one that sat down with her
all right putting these up around town to bank
robbery suspect and he's a real creep of course
about rescheduling our date well I can't make off
of Kim campus all eyes are on me you won't have
to I'll come to you 9pm Corrections [__] sounds
romantic you want to go on another date after all
that [__] unless of course it has something
to do with the fact that she's figured out what
he is she knows that you're right that's right
your job is to guard that diary while I'm gone
I'll be back as soon as I can
it's not a date it's a quid pro quo for almost
getting him disemboweled a quid pro whoa
okay you can open your eyes now
oh wow what a date how romantic [Music]
how do you feel about scary movies this is
like the best day ever oh she got a smile going
oh oh no oh
are they watching legally blind
[Music]
there's definitely a suspect's bike all
right he couldn't get too far on foot
so you guys spread out I'm gonna check down
by the lake you don't know Uncle Fester man
you can keep trying to push me away it's
not gonna work who almost killed you I
survived beginner's luck I'm tougher than you
think you want to see you're making a mistake
probably his mistake to make oh my God he's
gonna go for it never been this tense during
it oh it almost happened oh Ugg I'm not
gonna even ask what this is but I never
saw the two of you here you got it make sure
not to tell me about it later damn Wednesday
was not pulling back on that kiss yeah she
turned into it oh [__] diary thing [Music]
no no what are we implying right now
no no no you gotta be kidding me they
better be able to bring him back no they
wouldn't get some of Fester's electricity
no he's got to be alive so they wouldn't
kill him off [Music] get him on the table
do a back alley operation on him
[Music]
come on
oh come on thing
oh no she's crying no no [Music]
way they wouldn't I don't buy it are
they really come on It's gotta be a
fake out he's gone Wednesday no
he's not thing if you can hear me
if you die I will kill you
please maximum power Fester
[Music]
oh [__]
yes yes nice from behind the back cowards promised
that whoever did this to you will suffer it won't
be slow long and excruciatingly painful yes
is because it should be break out the rack
that was cruel the sheriff won't be far you need
to go I'll lay low here tonight keep an eye on
the patient I'll skedaddle in the morning come
back next season men are the next family reunion
it'll always be my favorite Wednesday
sure to tell pugsy that wow you guys we almost
lost thing right now it really had me going yeah
he wanted to determine if they were just Mindless
Killers or conscious of their actions what was his
conclusion yes killed by a Hyde before he could
reach one ironic if you suspect someone you need
to tell me why well you've ever done is go outside
and obstruct me true I am protecting our Livermore
family which also includes you in atoms if I could
protect everyone but you I would Mary should be
all right in the end I'm roon for I don't I don't
I don't know what I'm rooting for come with me
I have information about Mayo Walker's
murder okay good to see you too let's go
he's off my dad's computer seems he was trying
to track down someone Laurel Gates looks like
he started right after average day he must have
recognized her there according to the British
police report Laura was presumed drought but
nobody was ever recovered a likely story The Gates
mansion was purchased a year ago by a 90 year old
candy Eris she then mysteriously died and gave
all of her belongings to her caregiver Theresa
Oklahoma it's an anagram for Laurel Gates the
monster is called a hide it's been doing Laurel
spitting she controls it you know who Laurel is
what's up I was right because John
guessed it first you are correct
well done I know you're Laurel
Cates you've come back to Jericho
to seek your revenge and so did mayor
Walker which is why you had to kill him
I mean who better decide in and out of the
hospital undetected than a psychiatrist under
the guise of visiting another patient I hope
you're writing a recorder yeah please I honestly
have no idea what you're talking about there's
only one reason an overqualified psychiatrist
like yourself would settle in the inconsequential
Backwater that is Jericho hey I don't have time
to deal with your delusional fantasies I have
a patient emergency who savior do you know how
violently unpredictable a hide can be or would
you plan to have Xavier committed before you
could turn on YouTube Wednesday you need help more
help than I can give you Who you calling Xavier
I'm going to recommend you stay in a juvenile
psychiatric facility for observation oh please
you and I both know I'd be running that place in a
week [Laughter] time's up Laurel Checkmate I hope
you were wearing a recorder even though she did
not confess she did not incriminate herself but
she is suspicious as hell principal Weems it's
Valerie kimbot Wednesday Adams just barged into
my office during our appointment [Laughter] was
completely irrational yep that's right irrational
oh the hides in there damn is my
theory about to be wrong foreign
was wrong you [__] that's
definitely Tyler though I gotta retire
who would be controlling the hide is it him she's
gone baby I have to come back to dead oh damn well
you left that in my room actually
you left it in thing how long have
you been seeing kinbot you've been
spying on me right kung fu fight
work your painting has been improving
I enjoy this one in particular
Fizz Ron's inhaler doing in
your shed are Eugene's glasses
whoa are these stalker images you took
of me don't forget your latest edition
they're plants necklace no no somebody planted
that stuff drop the knife down on your knees
damn you framed me I'm being set
up I should have let Rowan kill you
oh damn shadow of a doubt
Wednesday definitely Tyler
what episode left
a few days the place gets trashed and thing
almost dies someone's got to look out for you
too what happened to booming with Yoko I just
decided I needed a few more boundaries I mean
it's racist man thanks what he missed you oh I
miss him too wow I'm sorry about Xavier I'm not
he's a liar and a killer cook them thing may have
blabbed about your date with Tyler so how'd it go
it was interrupted I heard Tyler's working the
late shift the date shift come on let's get some
Cliffhanger maybe Katie yes come on then you
should lock your doors there's some real sick
people out there yeah my dad told me what happened
to Xavier pretty nuts like I always seems so
normal it has made me reevaluate things does that
mean you're ready to be more than friends [Music]
dang and she closed her eyes but it's definitely
not a love drawing she kind of blinked
oh oh a little smile [Music] oh [Music] oh no
[Music]
yes yep yep yep yep yep [Music]
you okay you need to go what what's
wrong Wednesday's gonna like vomit
of course the first
to be a cycle serial killing but you don't know
if he's a monster on purpose or not [Music]
right to the pilgrim World underneath
the pilgrim World sign well you did it
yeah I know I know you won you beat me in the
prediction game of Wednesday how's it feel
s good none of the episode matters now none of
the information we need to talk about anything
else nope no prominent guessing now it's time
for a smugness and gloating now it's time for an
episode eight reaction where we sit there patting
ourselves on the back Fanning myself the entire
time yes it is a plant shade here please some
palm plant shade can I get you another Mai Tai sir
um yeah one sec let me just uh clumps this one
little lap oh what uh no that was an exciting
episode it was a very very exciting episode with a
lot of Thrills and making sure that a big trailer
did not drop while we're filming this and no
no it hasn't okay we're good uh so yeah there's
um there's uh you talk you talk for a while yeah
this is a very thrilling penultimate episode I
mean me like my my mind goes I know we're basking
in the glory of Victory right now but also I mean
I was I love uh getting a chance to see Uncle
Fester in the action I mean you know he was
not like the the main point of the episode he
doesn't like take the focus of the episode the
way like The Addams Family coming to visit does
but I was just really pleased and and excited
to have his quirky energy along for the ride and
uh and yeah helping out with the investigation I
can see that in the future if the show persists
Beyond season two and you know further down the
line every season having like a Fest drip so
to look forward to love that and uh and yeah
satisfying sort of uh Crest toward the end of the
mystery I was really worried for thing which you
know it's one of those things where you're like
they can't kill them they're not gonna kill him
but in the moment you're like damn this feels like
they could well it seems like Tyler doesn't know
that he is it is the height that's how yeah that's
how it seems to be playing it at least yeah yeah
so there's a chance so I mean so she definitely
wasn't Laurel though I guess not I mean I feel
like she still could be there could but she would
be the ideas that she would she was controlling
the hide yeah and it doesn't seem as though that
was the case unless they do bring up that piece
of lore about like whoever uh you know like if
they transform back or whatever and their true
form is revealed to somebody then that person like
gains the control so maybe they control like trans
what if it's Christina Richie you know that makes
a lot more sense it would make a lot of sense and
she has been the benevolent character in plain
sight who we haven't really peeled back much at
all but there was no way she would be remember
this episode the thing that threw a a hole in
that theory for me and why I had never brought
it up was because and I didn't know about that
until this episode be oh the other thing that
I thought like wouldn't be working with Tyler
or an in conjunction with him because of the scene
when Eugene died and we saw someone go into the
cave yeah somebody both Tyler and Christina
Ritchie were at the dance and they made that
really clear geographically they were both at the
dance when that went down yeah so I don't know how
um because I kept going like well who wasn't
at the dance could be Tyler's data I suppose
um but I wonder I wonder too because yeah that is
a good point but regardless I thought this was a
fantastic episode it had a a really great balance
of Whimsy felt very Adam's Family whenever and it
didn't feel like it was tonally conflicting with
the show that we currently have it managed to keep
the momentum and the pulse uh revved up I know
I'll feed you soon and managed to keep the pulse
and the momentum really revved up uh while also
providing us that quirky sensibility of Adam's
Family five because you know like the the one
with Morticia and Gomez was a bit more on that
you know emotional Gothic horror side whereas the
the stuff with Uncle Fester has a little bit more
of that quirky fun Macabre humor so it managed to
blend pretty well I thought with the current you
know uh modern day Wednesday show that we have
here of investigative Supernatural mysteries
of foot and it was exciting it was exciting time
I really liked Fred armisen's portrayal of Uncle
Fester not like one to go this is moving up to
my childhood or something I enjoyed what he did
I thought I thought he didn't steal didn't
try to steal the show and I thought him and
um General Ortega had great chemistry and
I loved um seeing Jenna Ortega become more
emotional I love the challenge I like the idea of
when they choose to reveal that it's Tyler because
this is her most vulnerable episode she breaks
down into tears at the thought of losing thing
um she admits to missing a friendship with Enid
and and opens up about that she takes the step to
engage in Romance with Tyler at the end and just
when you've become trusting uh it just collapses
in front of you everything that you thought you
just did right you'd sell the case you become
open and banned this is why I don't trust people
yeah you know it's uh what's that what's that word
called prophecy something self-fulfilling prophecy
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah and it's so I think
it's a good like character portrayal of her maybe
it's Christina Ritchie but that just wouldn't make
sense with the cave scene yeah I was trying to
yeah I'm trying to do the Charlie Day yarn mat
in my head because yeah there's been little clues
that she's more than just the good human teacher
nor me teacher there's been a little clue that
she's more and so with line up and then she comes
into town you know so well in the Laura Gates
thing yeah like I I it would be sort of a big
it would be a Twist of some sort because of the
family's attitude toward uh you know people at
Nevermore than to have her like infiltrating the
place essentially and you know working from the
inside would be pretty Sinister but also it makes
me wonder what the long game is of that because it
seems like she's been here a while I can't exactly
remember if they clarify how long Miss Thornhill
has been at the school but you know it seems as
though I don't know yeah it's good I like being
able to go into the ending episode with you know
still a certain amount of mysteries especially
after all the Tyler stuff because I feel like
that's kind of a nice tempering is like you have
the Tyler mystery that in some ways you could
argue is one of the easier ones to figure out
um but they've still managed to
have a certain I don't know man
Tyler that's true that's true not everybody
second episode once you walked out of that
therapy session I was like definitely yeah that's
the one it's a 100 bags yeah print that one
everybody we're going home yeah yeah no for sure
for sure some you know it was it was a satisfying
mystery in the way they drove it out wasn't
like it was pretty predictable and then they
were trying to make you not think it's him yes and
then when you're penultimate or your like Xavier's
arrested you're like okay so it's a hundred
percent done yeah yeah and so I'm wondering
too like they I think they've done a nice job of
laying down Clues and then when Wednesday is given
they do say not to trust the premonitions they do
they do and that's that's the [__] no you can't
you can't hop off every house right now we got one
more episode God damn it yeah I mean well and that
makes you wonder like can somebody like literally
from the outside can somebody affect these Visions
in any way is somebody like planting images
in Wednesday's head you know is there further
framing happening but even so like I I appreciate
the way that they've smeared some of these details
around because we've kept track of a lot of things
and then yeah having uh Xavier be framed having
everybody's little items and effects come up uh in
that process like I don't know I'm still I'm still
sitting with a good amount of mystery I'm like
okay principal Weems kind of dastardly but at the
same time I I always get where she argues she's
coming from so I'm I I I can't fully put it on her
unless she can control more stick sick more
people I'm just like the only one who wasn't
at the dance was the sheriff which I feel
like it could I don't know there could be
a thing where it's him and and the guy ducking
into the cave did look like the sheriff to me
and I wonder if that could be a very human sort
of explanation is like maybe he you know came
out of hide form and his dad caught it and you
know I would think that someone I think they're
missing that there's a third person in on it
I feel like the dad is in coordination with
this yeah maybe to protected he's not the one
controlling Tyler yeah he's not the one sicking
him on people he's probably just trying to like
cover up that anybody could ever find out that
Tyler is this way I don't know and we won't know
because we're not gonna watch the last episode we
were done with the show now we're gonna leave it
here at this Victory he'll we'll continue it in
season two yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah alrighty
guys well I'm going to bask in the glory for
a while do it do it it was nice good Legally
Blonde moment too so that was a lovely date
I would love to go on a date like that that was a
great date good on Tyler and spider website where
I want to roll around man that's where I want to
be I want stuff crawling on me terrible I want to
you know get tetanus cutting myself on something
rusty let's go to a theater you know but that's
it that's that's a normie date while you're
going to the theater paying 1950s films hey
that's how I treat everyone at theaters hey look
at my popcorn We Love Popcorn I want to wait till
the movie's over during the movie Yeah clean it
up now because I'm gonna spray my feet out and I
don't want to have anything crunching underneath
it well I watch my movie alrighty guys well
did you guess it was Tyler I bet most people
did if you didn't guess it was Tyler
comment below and we will be crying
yes it's pretty obvious it's
okay it's okay we got it though
imagine if you didn't think it was Tyler
yeah it would be an embarrassing reaction
uh I just I I Justice for Xavier man Justice for
Xavier um well guys leave your thoughts down below
subscribe leave a like leave a like leave a
like and um hey let's end this with a patron
pandemic Jones hi pandemic Jones
if you were a hide I would love two to
instruct you to go after all kinds of people
I'm talking blind way yes I'm talking the norm
the normies especially I'm talking Tyrone Magnus
I'd have you take out all the reactors every
single one of them now only reaction Channel I'm
daunting left standing it would be the ultimate
pandemic of reactors falling to their graves yes
with only one immune to this pandemic we would be
the vaccine we can bottle and sell it that's right
I want to keep reacting pay us monthly because
the vaccine only works a month at a time
you only get immunity to be our patreon for tier
yeah to go to the vaccine yeah so pandemic I want
to thank you because I know that I wouldn't
even need to control you to do it I would just
ask you kindly and you would go yeah sure why
not I'll go ahead nice guy I'll do anything for
you what kind of hide we have over here High
Tides is what we got with the pandemic Jones
PJ thank you for being a massive support and
being part of our page for so long uh you are
one of the sexiest rejects we got sexiest so
looking forward to talking with you more soon
I'm assuming you watched the show I think I've
seen your comments in these videos I've been
avoiding the comments in the last couple videos
because I'm like a little afraid but uh don't
know what's gonna happen to the end Still Still I
haven't got a room for me I'm very lucky I haven't
got anything over me unfortunately yeah well
done I don't know anything yeah I'm very lucky
um all right guys we'll talk
with y'all soon thank you PJ
foreign